last week Axia was not doing the roster
and residency been Feingold was and I
was actually teaching all-girls chess
camp but not just any all-girls chess
camp this was quite extraordinary I'm
probably the strongest in terms of like
age and rating in America ever I would
imagine because it was super strong
there was actually a 12 year old master
in the tournament who defeated Irina
crushes record pretty recently for
becoming the youngest female master in
America her name is Annie Wang and there
are several other very young chess
masters in that group really exciting
because it's gonna change the
composition of the u.s. women's Chess
Championship quite soon I believe
probably within like five years those
girls will gain another 100 or 200
points and they'll all be playing in the
women's and who knows maybe one of them
will be playing in the championship
which is actually open to both genders
right so this is a game from a women's
championship a while ago where I was
playing white and here I was playing
against Anna Hahn who won the Women's
Championship herself once since then
she's she kind of got into finance and
started doing really well and didn't
play as much chess anymore but she was a
regular on the women's championship
scene for many years and did quite well
this position interest in me though
because she was a little higher rated
than me and I did win this game but it
surprised me after the game that she
didn't see my move here cuz to me it
seemed kind of obvious and I think
that's a real clear example of both the
theme that I'm gonna demonstrate and
also something that's just inherent to
chess itself it's always easier to see
your own ideas than to see your
opponent's ideas right because seeing
your opponent ideas requires you to look
really critically at your position and
their potential weaknesses so generally
almost everybody has an easier time
finding our own strategic and tactical
ideas than finding the ones that our
opponents trying to play against ass so
something to keep in mind and door
baretsky talks about this a lot in his
books
and he causes prophylactic thinking
trying to put yourself in your opponents
shoes at all times is a really crucial
skill so that you can kind of bridge
that distance between you know maybe
you're 20 maybe if you're 18 hundred you
might be 2,000 and finding tactics for
yourself and 1604 finding tactics for
your opponent and combine them together
you get 1800 so that maybe you can
bridge that gap and just become a
stronger player so here white to move
what do you think the best move is what
ya work these XY
right
exactly work to be six it's it's a it's
a pretty simple example of the theme I
mean looks like what should be better
here right like I've got a bishop that's
a better piece but if I don't have a way
to do something here I shouldn't be much
right the pawn the blacks pawns are a
little bit weaker my King is better as
well on g2 so everything about my
position is a little bit better but I
really need something to increase my
advantage so work d6
and I have a really good position but
the reason I wanted to show this move
was actually because it's the theme of
our lecture today which is something I
learned from the US chess school
actually the girls are so smart they
taught me a lot of things and there was
one position in particular that we're
gonna get to a little later where I
showed it to them and they told me one
of the girls who was very well-read she
was always reading like so many chess
books only 14 but you could tell she
knew all about chess history and the top
players and she called she told me about
the word collinear collinear actually
pretty she pronounced it collinear or
not collinear collinear sounds cooler
sounds kind of French doesn't sound like
some kind of math term so colinear is a
term that was coined by John Donne in
reference to chaste it has a math
meaning before that which means moving
the piece backwards or forwards on a
line where you could also capture
something right so for some reason those
moves are considered to be harder to
find because usually you inherently if
you're if you're any good at chess
you've probably reached a level where
you kind of automatically look at
captures and jacks because that's how
you get from like 600 to 1200 right you
know like if you're able to always look
at the text and captures because those
are the forcing sequences which often
end in checkmate or just winning all
your opponent's pieces so the problem is
the better you get that tendency can
occasionally come back to harm you right
you're looking like for instance a lot
of players will just start looking at
work takes real care it's actually a
really terrible move or fixer rock right
because you you acquiesce the UH the
file but still there's something going
on in people's minds where they will
look for it look at
that even for just a millisecond because
you got a look at trades to get good
that's what wins material and then when
you get better you have to learn when
not to trade a very crucial skill so
yeah work three six and I won the game
it's it's too much pressure for lying
now I'm going to show you some other
examples I mean don't worry about that
we're gonna come back okay now in honor
of the syncro Cup I didn't want to show
you one example from none other than the
founder of the st. Louis chess club and
the president here Rex Sinquefield the
SEC team was actually published in the
New York Times and it's a really cool
move that you play here which probably
be obvious to you after the last example
but still what do you do here is black
so black to move
this one's actually a little harder than
the last one yeah we're t5 is the moves
excellent move because it's a probably a
tiny bit harder because generally
backward moves are a little harder to
see them forward moves and Chasse
so the idea here is not to look at
trading which allows perpetual x'
but to find this like very beautiful
solid move why is it not actually I'm
having some trouble once I can I'm
trouble actually moving the pieces here
some reason it's not actually going
through the game okay there I think
that's working now so work to g5 and now
it's very difficult for white because if
we take on g5 we just get to close
everything down I'm gonna probably
taking with the they both look fine
honestly taking with the H or the Jeep
on and then then it's just going to be
too much for for white because the e4
pawn and the c3 pawn are both gonna be
under fire you can't really defend both
of them at all
so this position is just totally
crushing for black now but it's a it's a
tough it's kind of a tough move to find
because it's very patient especially if
you haven't been looking at colinear
moves it's really hard to find that's
the thing everything is harder to find
in practice than it is in theory if you
look at a position in a book in a
chapter about a certain subject it's
gonna be about five times easier to find
it in that book then it will over the
board so that's why in general it's good
to look at a lot of really simple
tactics before a big tournament because
those are you want to be able to find
simple things quickly in chess as well
as finding really deep things so let's
look at some other examples so an
after-work g5 I think you know black
white just doesn't even have really much
moves at all right so it's kind of a
very clear example but almost a lot of
chess players would start looking at
forcing things like works you want in
Queens you on and trying to calculate
all that
so back to
I'm gonna go so in this position what do
you think white played
again work v6 yeah so now you're gonna
get good at finding these types of moves
right man this this annotation is
actually pointing out a nice move that
if white please ePHI if you're trying to
kind of highlight how horrendous this
bishop is which it is for the moment
black now we'll play Wyatt right
basically the same type of idea like an
outpost for the rook on the file to stop
white from out posting his own work on
the file and now even though black even
though black has that terrible bishop on
b7 and you're gonna kind of have to deal
with your sheep on right so that it
helps them hold the balance a little bit
so instead of work to be six and again
like before it's very difficult now for
black because we exert so much control
over the position and we're ready to
play rough do you want as well it's not
going forward for some reason I might
have to close this up and bring it up
again let me say you know it'll be okay
for the next one I know what would you
do is but as ye
right work to see you succeed so II owe
actually Bishop eight-six first I think
that works c6 right away first it's good
also though I think so I don't really
wait is there something let me look wait
a minute
yeah let's see what the difference is
move let's try to find let's try to
discover what the difference is somebody
thinks that there is a big difference
let's see so do you think Bishop h6
throwing in Bishop h6 immediately as
necessary is the question Bishop h6 of
course forces Wyatt right Bishop h6
forces at sex which is got to be a nice
thing to add but what is the difference
so if we're c6 immediately upon c6 Queen
c6 b5 do you see some defense there for
a black that it I don't see any defense
there either yeah we used to be hidden
stole just taken a sex so we did
somebody something after work after and
then what did you think
wait what do you mean that's the idea
yeah b5 but I think there might be a way
to have more counter play here for some
reason I agree that there might be
something here I'm trying to figure out
what it is I think the one difference
might be maybe it's slightly less
terrible it might know this looks pretty
bad as well but it might be like
slightly slightly better because notice
that when the pawn is on it f6 we also
have checks on d5 which make the
position even more overwhelming in lines
like after Queen c7 or something yeah
but it's honestly they're a bit but it
doesn't it doesn't seem like Brooke c6
right away is a massive error but Bishop
h6 flowing in Bishop h6 s6 and then
following it up with work c6 even
stronger now because now after Rick
takes c6 pawn takes c6 you're also
coming in with Queen d5 possibilities in
Queen f7 so it's even more crushing
right
that's a good question yeah I was trying
to find a difference it might be
something like that
or oh you know what I think I see it u6
is one possibility yeah of course
there's a better move here yeah now that
I see it it's so obvious that's the
problem when you when you look at when
you look at things in the wrong order we
were looking for some reason we were
looking at rook takes c6 pawn takes c6
which is definitely not the first thing
to look at here if you're black so
that's that and that's the whole disease
that I was talking about looking at the
trades before looking at other moves so
actually six I don't think II six is the
right move but yeah II five right away
is definitely right that's got to be
good and unless unless pawn takes c6
works but it doesn't seem too because
after Queen takes c6 I don't see any me
there yeah it's kind of messy let's take
a look kind of interesting what do you
do here probably you can go you probably
have to go at six Queen takes up six and
Queen c7 right look like it works though
because of eSATA
yeah what else what else what else do we
defend here so you must play at six and
then after Queen takes f6 or work c7
same thing though EE seven looks real
good
but I guess at least you can sacrifice
and play Queen c7 there right you guys
follow me so I'm saying like f6 here
Queen f6 works e7 and now stopping the
mate you play e7 so now in order to stop
the maid again we have to sacrifice
ourselves but even here it's better it's
not doesn't look like resigns yet so
pick up two pawns your two pawns though
so it's pretty good what's that
what's that but even here it's not so
clear because you don't have to play
Queen takes c6 you could also maybe
there's something interesting with Queen
takes d6 so works so Bishop h6
immediately and that's an example of new
order it's like good to see if you have
a good idea like rook c6 to try to add
moves like Bishop h6 and see if it
changes anything right I'm gonna skip a
few any other questions about that
position
skip skip ahead a little bit to a couple
that I wanted to look at
okay what to do in this position this
one is this one is kind of yeah this
one's interesting I don't know it's not
it's quite a clear example of collinear
the other ones but it's a cool position
so black to move if I kept showing new
positions with rook c6 and rook c5 I
mean any way would be it would be too
obvious with the answers right so this
is a little bit more of a combination of
the theme of collinear with the idea of
prophylaxis so prophylaxis idea that I
was talking about earlier which means
really anticipating your opponent's
ideas whether they're freeing ideas or
whether they're aggressive ideas it's
good to anticipate hmm worth d5 wait
that's exactly the point if we're t5
what's your plan okay good idea
so if 485 with the idea of work a5 if
your opponent is a smart person I mean
if they're a good chess player good
chess player and smart person I
definitely should not use those
synonymously but um it worked at e5 here
with the idea of work a5 what what my
white play to try to avoid disaster with
or other words losing all their pawns
but your boy Bishop to Bishop b6 okay
yeah well the problem with that hmm it
looks so it looks so artificial there's
a couple problems with it what's the
what's the most direct problem with
roofie sex so what is Bishop one III
defending against this money III is
defending against a key move that block
could play if you played riff d5 Bishop
b6
rook D to check would just win upon so
you you you you guard against one trap
and then you let me in with another
threat and granted this position is a
bit difficult to defend for why and the
reason for that is the black Bishop is
better than the black white bishop and
the black work is better than the white
rook so it's just like purely much
better for black and whites the one who
has to kind of defend but after rook to
you five instead of defending with
Bishop e6 what else what other possible
defensive ideas are that I use your
ideas just to play work a5 and take my
pawn right I can't play where k1 because
Bishop takes be too simple idea work d5
to work a five so this is another thing
it's kind of a process of elimination
here for ye your position is pretty bad
so if you can find a way to stop work a5
and just take on a two you might just
want to play it right and then you still
would be under some pressure but it
can't be that bad no c4 is interesting
so I don't like c-4 as much because we
could just you're trying to like if I
take on Poisson you're trying to play
work so you want at the end of the
variation right so see Ford's interest
me move because oh sorry with d5 after
work t5c for here
I play I was thinking about this this
and this but I guess you're just gonna
play rook here now and your argument is
that you're getting a lot of counter
play which see oh there's one issue here
no it's it's blacks move now I do see I
do see Bishop trying to see if Bishop d2
is any good here I don't think it's that
special though after Bishop d2 work
takes c6 work at five check you can just
go to e2 and that doesn't really lead to
much so I think actually after c4 I
probably have a better move probably I
should just do what I was going to do
all along which is work a five because
it actually doesn't change anything if I
don't get distracted by the idea of a
free pod and just go with my original
plan because you still can't play a3 I
just take it and you still can't play
with anyone because I just take care
right yeah exactly so don't get caught
up just because you offered me a pawn in
a different way I still should take it
the way that I wanted to take it
originally which would not only win a
pawn but also you're not getting any
activity right like you have to work a5
you're not getting any activity here
because well you can try working you on
that would be a way to get activity but
first of all yeah I mean I can just take
all your pawns
you're not getting your knight and
you're not getting enough activity right
you're not actually winning any of your
pawns
so what else we'll see friend a pretty
good idea actually it's like a good
attempt because they're kind of teasing
me you want me to take on c3 and then
you get a get counter play but instead I
decided just to go over k5 so what else
in general when you're down in material
when you're when you're on the defensive
like this you do kind of want to seek
out trades so c4 is a good idea in that
respect a3 is the correct move yes
and now after a pawn takes a three pawn
takes a three it's not totally clear it
looks like white is coming to the
defense a little bit here right
so instead what other moves are there
here work t5 is definitely one of the
moves that I would look at first
yeah so work to be eight is a very
clever idea here so basically it has the
same ideas rook d5 but what is it stop
it stop 283 why does it stop at a three
because we can't take it because this
pawn is pinned right so this is also one
of those like I kind of consider this
more like a quiet move or a mysterious
rook move is I think the names of it to
claim it in that it seems it seems so
passive to play work be it but it's
obviously very aggressive because the
idea after work b8 is to just play work
b5 in or k5 except now we just take away
your one way of defending against there
right so work be a really brilliant move
I guess it's collinear in the sense that
the work is going on a square it's
probably not it's not as great an
example in that respect but it's a
really cool move so I included it anyway
hey route the v8 and now now whites in
trouble oh I showed a three but it's
much more difficult for white to defend
here because work being B 5 and a 5 is
coming into the position with good
effects and notices your Bishop e6 idea
is also prevented alright now I want to
show you the position that started all
this
this is white to move and win so this is
the position we showed in the girls
school in the u.s. chess school to the
all-girls class and it took them a
little while to solve this and they were
mostly 2,200 to 2002 2200 was basically
the ratings of the group a few 1900s so
but all of them like really studying a
lot of tactics and openings they're
really serious about chess so take a few
minutes and try to figure out how to win
here for Wyatt and the important thing
here is look at your opponent's
possibilities too so don't think it's
not gonna be that easy right you might
see a line that looks pretty good but
you better make sure that you're looking
for blacks defensive ideas because
otherwise there's a good chance they'll
just be wrong
give it some time like at least two
minutes at least two minutes before we
before we try
all right who's got an idea yeah do you
you found a defense against it all right
what do you what do you think well if
Queen to be to check then Bishop f6 yeah
that's a really good idea but wait that
black does have a good defensive move
there so a bishop d4 check Bishop f6
Queen B - what can black do to defend
yeah Kim G sevens a pretty good
defensive move there what was your idea
Kyle similar Wow I thought of that -
that was one of my first ideas because
one of the issues here is that what's
what's whites what's blacks counter
playing well I do a lot of the obvious
see one meeting yeah exactly so you guys
are on the right track that you're
looking for moves at both attack and
defend but it's not that one
that's a really good idea - that looks
really attractive because they're also
Bish's idea to repeat everybody is
Bishop before then bishop have sex in
them queen c4 with the idea that if
Queen takes c4 you have what well you
have to take that six and then yeah
you're winning abuse right so but
instead be 50 for Bishop f6 Queen c4
black has a good defensive move a tricky
defensive move I first I thought King g7
defended there but I don't think it's a
very good defensive move he was a way
better one
after a bishop d4 check Bishop f6 Queen
c4 black has a really good move lady a
because that that allows Queen g8 yeah
that was kind of the idea of Queens
before her that 95 is a very good move
yeah because now we can't play Queen
takes d5 because of what scene you want
again and if you play this takes up 6
then what yeah you got to work on it man
that's why I'm making you do it that's
how you become that's how you okay no no
I'm happy to repeat it by that being I'm
happy to repeat it but that being said
I'm doing it on purpose also partly
because sometimes chess pays pops up
there correct answers if I play too many
moves and I don't want to give I don't
want to give this one away make sense
exactly
but Bristol Bishop d4 Bishop f6 Queen C
495 with the idea that after Bishop
takes f6 Knight takes f6 defends
everything those Knights are just such a
pesky defenders they're good at
defending Kings you know so the site's
nice that it's on c7 for them all that
once it gets to s6 it's like the party's
over
of course the most direct thing to look
at is Bishop d4 check Bishop f6 Queen e7
right but as usual in our variations
here that loses - I
yeah I'm Queen Ceylon yeah
but that's like the first thing I'm sure
most of you looked at probably yeah yeah
yeah
you guys are so close to getting it I'm
not giving any hands bishop d4 check it
is correct yeah yeah wow you guys are
good at the process of elimination thing
before check Bishop f6 are the first two
moves okay you guys got it right we can
go now well I just said 9595 a really
good defensive move 95 is a really good
defense yeah so that's not good
yeah you can't week to repeat that again
so you're saying after before check
Bishop f6 Queen c4 Knight d5 you'll just
you'll just play Queen takes c6 well I
could also take something else
yeah I can take on d4 so I take on d4
bishops of opposite in bishops of
opposite color in game and but yeah it's
not its previous first of all yeah I
mean it's not it's not the answer
I knew Oh [ __ ] it's about as I call her
a very Josh and you have a win my for
Sarah the combination of those two
things making that not the correct
answer
this is incredibly hard beautifying
Bishop g5 right now but I can wait I can
pay there right yeah yeah and then I can
drop my Bishop back that's the problem
now I can control the diagonal also I
already said that this would be four
bits of Essex's alright I gave you guys
that don't go don't worry it took the US
chess school this long we saw that two
out they were still working on it and it
took me a long time as well yeah that's
what the theme of this move is once you
see it you know it's the right amount of
and it's really annoying
it took me forever to find it and when I
saw it I was like it's one of those like
head slap moments
well it's the same thing because it's
just a different reward or if you play
Bishop three for Bishop f6 Queen B -
it's exactly the same position is
playing Queen B - Bishop f6 Bishop c4
and then you just plays King g7 so that
is a good idea but it doesn't work for
the same reason so Bishop d4 Bishop f6
and then Bishop b2 and you guys like
that idea but side your does not to say
that yeah yeah that's a great move
it's such a good move it says right
because they still can't take on b2
right cuz mate and now you're
threatening what after a Bishop d4
Bishop f6 Bishop you - what's your
threat yeah look somebody said it just
Joseph did you say it okay I thought I
heard it I heard somebody muttering
Bishop d4 Bishop f6 Bishop e2 what's the
threat for a white
very strong threat whoa fred is thinking
thinking too long and computer dying
there's 50 for Bishop f6 Bishop b2 you
have a big threat it's already been
mentioned b2b isn't baby I'm Bishop g4
check Bishop f6 Bishop detail
yeah Queen e7 is a threat right because
you can't take the Queen because of the
pin and you can't take on b2 because of
why Queen F ain't me
yeah so that's the big idea that after
Bishop do four check Bishop f6 you can't
play Queen e7 because of me
but after Bishop d4 check Bishop f6
Bishop b2 you're actually powerless to
stop Queen e7 because if King g7 we have
Queen e7 anyway right so no rule against
people on staff getting the questions
right no no that's pretty good what's
raining oh yeah hurry up that's very
impressive yeah so you're allowed
so Bishop d4 Bishop f6 oh that should
have made it easier ah yeah yeah yeah
ah but you we didn't see Queen 87 you
didn't see that was unstoppable
oh there is one more cool thing if
Bishop d2 Bishop f6 Bishop b2 what if
black plays Knight to e8
that's right it's just mating after
Queen takes the eight queen takes a
bishop takes after that sex is mating
now I'll put on the board just for fun
such a great move it should be - it's so
so aesthetic like if Bishop takes - D -
Queen B - is mating and now Queen e7 is
is just unstoppable really really nice
move so the point being all this 98 now
the prettier way to win is of course no
more moves checkmate
but you know a lot of this comes into
something which it's not even really a
lot of these problems were tactical or
like somewhat strategic but really
ultimately it's looking at moves which
are and captures which tend to be a
little bit less intuitive for people so
that instinct of always capturing is so
ingrained that some of these moves kind
of force that out of us and the stronger
the player the more likely they are to
look for ways to keep the tension keep
the pieces on the board and this is a
another really good example of that so
thanks guys that was fun and good job
for the Bishop b2 move there I'll see
you guys all at the Ziegfeld Cup in just
a month
you